[Music]
is it too early to look forward to 2021
apparently not just look at the
channel's videos and you can have that
feeling that i
along with everyone else is ready to
kiss this chaotic year goodbye and keep
an optimistic outlook for the year to
come which is a shame because i honestly
think that as far as anime is concerned
2020 has been a pretty decent year
however most of the shows that i really
like this year are sequels and part of
me thinks that we should be judging a
year by its non-sequels so here we go
the top 10 most anticipated shows for
2021 and i
intentionally didn't include sequels in
this one remakes well
we'll have quite a number of them
[Music]
the remakes just keep coming this year
with the next 2021 title
spriggan nope this isn't a fantasy story
about mythical creatures despite what
the title might suggest at first glance
this is why i was surprised when i first
checked the title out and saw that
spriggan is actually more of a military
title and what an engaging one it seems
to be the legendary noah's ark has
apparently been
found in turkey such a legendary
artifact would be a hot commodity and
the americans are on the way to grab
hold of it in the name of global
supremacy however standing in their way
is the special
organization called spriggan you anime
teams up with gene but their mission
isn't an easy one nothing's ever easy if
it requires overcoming the psionic
powers of the american colonel mcdougall
the pentagon or spriggan who will come
out on top so who's up for some sci-fi
military action this 2021 this title was
actually a late 90s movie and the themes
really showed nonetheless i'm curious as
to how the story will unfold this time
as a two-episode ona
despite having no exact release date yet
we should be getting something soon
enough
[Music]
you know what's coming back but isn't
featured in the list because it's a
sequel
bleach yep you heard that right but
before getting to that
how about taking a trip down memory lane
and revisiting one of the biggest
conflicts in the series
now you can do so with the help of the
newest bleach mobile game in stores
bleach immortal soul if you're not aware
bleach immortal soul is a turn-based rpg
that takes you through the story of the
bleach anime while letting you collect
your favorite characters and fight
alongside them the game's about to reach
the climax of the first major part of
the story and the wizards join the
decisive battle against eisen and his
top as spiders in fake karakura town
they're not the only ones getting a
chance to show off even the espadas in
their awesome released forms have become
available
gather your allies and take on eisen in
the all-new defend karakora town mode
if you feel that this is the game for
you i've left a promo code down below
follow the link and get these nifty
rewards don't forget you can also finish
seven daily logins and gain access to
the adorable child form nil
hope to see you in the game ah
eden zero okay i'll give everyone a few
seconds to laugh at the designs that
look like
fusions of fairy tale characters and
make jokes on my shima recycling
characters
you done okay back to business to be
fair i think the eden zero gets
overlooked more than it deserves to be
i'm sure that the character designs have
a lot to do with it but having read the
manga i think that it's a pretty decent
series in its own right
eden zero tells of a space adventure
starring shiki granbell having lived his
life amongst machines rebecca and happy
appear
yep that's right marking the first time
human presence comes into gram bell
kingdom in a century things start
getting dangerous and shiki has to take
to the skies and explore the world
beyond with his new friends if you
enjoyed fairy tale you're sure to like
this one if not please give it a try i
admit it feels the same at times but i
think the eden zero gives a nice twist
to the usual fantasy worlds that we've
come to expect from hiromashima
[Music]
cult classic uzumaki is finally getting
an anime adaptation
and it's coming this 2021. is it just me
or is this one of the most popular
horror manga recently
even now i still see some discussion on
it and i still see the physical copies
of the manga in my local bookstores the
staying power is just
amazing considering uzumaki is a 90s
manga in a genre that's not exactly too
mainstream in the anime and manga world
then again can you expect anything less
from the master of horror himself junji
ito uzumaki tells of a town that's been
plagued with a curse
it's a curse involving spirals something
that kirei goshima seems to take note of
after all the curse strikes near to her
afflicting her father who sets off a
series of horrific events
often involving spirals and snails still
wondering what the hype's all about for
uzumaki
well 2021 is your friend and you can
finally see what the talk is all about
tokyo revengers joins the freydis 2021
and it's our next entry
[Music]
well it's one of those time travel plots
again and this time we get it with a
dash of gang warfare it didn't take too
long but 2017's tokyo revengers will be
getting its much-awaited anime
adaptation in 2021 what is it about you
might ask well it's about some guy named
takamiji hanagaki things aren't looking
too good for him but the downward spiral
continues when he finds out that his
ex-girlfriend hinata has been murdered
by the notorious tokyo manji
gang as luck would have it he finds
himself traveling through time 12 years
in the past to be specific when he was
still in a relationship with the girl
realizing that he can still save hinata
dakimichi decides to join the ranks of
the tokyo manji and find a way to
rewrite the future
and rescue her from such a cruel fate
now here's a unique twist to the change
the past route of anime storytelling
having read the manga i know that it
would only be a matter of time before
tokyo revenges will get an anime
adaptation and i honestly think that
this will be the sleeper hit
of the season
[Music]
you get a remake you get a remake
everyone gets a remake
shaman king is our next entry on the
list
[Music]
we've officially clocked in a three
remake so far and this is the biggest
and most recognizable one by far
shaman king after nearly two decades is
finally set for a remake this 2021 that
looks to set the course right after what
happened in the 2000 series this time
the series is marketed as being one that
will follow a manga something that the
original series failed to do after
around 20 episodes in i dare say
shaman king is one of the pioneers in
the whole supernatural battle manga
genre you see every 500 years
one such tournament is held which pits
shamans against each other in a
tournament
where its winners get the power to
reshape the world as they choose our
protagonist
the carefree and easygoing yo asakura
finds himself becoming partners with the
ghost of a samurai and in the process
begins his foray into the shaman fight
and the world of the spirits looking to
claim victory and becoming
shaman king i'm sure that i'm not the
only one who has this title as a
childhood favorite and i really wonder
how it matches up now in 2021
after all the anime landscape has
changed drastically in the span of two
decades ironically reflecting one of the
themes of the series about change and
adapting to the times will shaman king's
remake be a big success
only time will tell
[Music]
we head close to the top three territory
with the number four entry on the list
the way of the house husband now this is
a rather late edition
but the hype is real when it got
announced just recently i can clearly
recall a lot of my friends getting so
excited now what is the series all about
and why is everyone so looking forward
to it immortal tatsu is a name that's
long struck fear in the hearts of both
the law and criminals alike however he
disappear and re-emerge as
a house husband having given up the path
of violence he decides to turn his life
around as an honest house husband now we
all know where this is headed
and tatsu finds himself overwhelmed by
the new battlefield that he stumbles
upon
misunderstandings comedy hijinks and
run-ins with his former peers follow him
as he tries to adapt to his new life now
i can already see why so many people are
looking forward to this the synopsis
alone provides so many opportunities for
comedy
endless laughs and truly entertaining
[Music]
moments
[Music]
third in our most anticipated list is
the one and only isakai that will
feature this time
mushoku tensei yes novel readers rejoice
the much awaited mushoku
tensei is making its way to television
this 2021 and i'm with you on the hype
trade the isakai wave doesn't seem to be
stopping anytime soon but along the way
it's given us some really cool shows
like
shield hero and re zero mushoku tensei
is
nothing like them i think the mushoka
tensei is more focused on excellent
world building and character redemption
instead of catching the attention of
people with its unique plot
it focuses more on the things that i'm
not sure can translate well in anime
format
of course much of the standards and
tropes that plague the genre find their
home in mushoku tensei you have the
trakun thing
you have the reincarnation thing and you
have the guy who finds himself a prodigy
in the new world even as a young boy oh
and he's a complete pervert too
nevertheless if the novel readers are to
be believed mushoku tensei
is really a lot better than you'd expect
from other titles in the genre for
something that's become so homogenized
the isekai genre sure is finding ways of
innovating and getting better
and better in small steady steps
for our second place we have to your
eternity
what does it mean to live what does it
mean to be human these are some
questions that we have trouble answering
but what about from the lens of an alien
organism to your eternity tries to take
a crack at it with its plot an
extraterrestrial being finds itself
landing on earth with the ability to
take over the form of things near it
it gains experience in doing so and
while it starts off with lifeless beings
it soon takes the shape of animals and
people in particular
it finds itself taking the place of a
boy in critical condition and under this
form
it goes on a journey seeking new
opportunities and looking for other
things that can only be experienced
through a human lens to your eternity
has a lot of people waiting for it and
rightfully so given its pedigree after
all it's from the author who brought us
a silent voice
it's too early to look at how things
will unfold in 2021 but as far as i can
see this is probably one of the top
contenders for the most artistic
and emotional titles
[Music]
we finish up with the most anticipated
new title this 2021
horimia it's no surprise that horimia
made it to this list
but it topping it well it's a bit early
but it's by far one of the most
anticipated rom-coms i've seen in a
while everyone can't stop talking about
it so i checked out the manga after
getting the blessing of my friends
and it is amazing it's quite easy to
summarize horemia two people who have
hidden sides run into each other and
start getting along however i think the
horimia's strength lies in its premise
and you do have to actually read or
watch it to see how much of a genius
title it is it never fails to give me
laughs and an ample dose of fluff have
we seen this setup a lot already
yes nevertheless as i just said now
horimia still manages to make it so
exciting and entertaining i'd say that
the manga is surprisingly good as it
goes on but that would be doing it a
disservice to the first parts of the
manga which i think are just great in
their own right i had a lot of fun
reading this manga and it just keeps
getting better i'm sure the rom-com fans
will be waiting for a big treat like
this
in 2021
[Music]
do you think the horror mia deserves to
be at the number one spot on the list of
upcoming new anime this 2021 or maybe
that you think that some other titles
more deserving
well whatever's the case i want to hear
from you if you have any requests for
future videos you can also write that
down and i'll see if i can get to it
sooner rather than later for now if you
enjoyed the content i'd like you to
subscribe and give this video a like
you can also recommend the channel to
your friends if you love the content and
it's one of the things that will make me
really really happy don't forget to
check out our sponsors game bleach
immortal souls links in the description
i'll be back in the next video so make
sure to watch out for it
see ya
[Music]